renewed signs if the pandemic is far
from over
new coronavirus infections are on the
rise across the nation
mass mandates are returning in some
places and city states and businesses
are rolling out vaccination requirements
this is the centers for disease control
and prevention warns
that vaccinated americans who become
infected while rare
can transmit the delta variant as easily
as those who are unvaccinated
those findings come as new cases are up
150 percent across the country
over the past two weeks hospitalizations
climbed
74 percent all of this is just about
half of the u.s population
is now fully vaccinated michael george
is here with the latest good morning
michael
michelle good morning some serious talk
from the cdc
they say the war has changed because of
the delta variant
while vaccinated people have a strong
level of protection new data shows
they can still spread the virus easily
if they happen to become infected
so now the government and businesses are
shifting their tactics
masks went back on in disneyland
yesterday for anyone
vaccinated or not who steps indoors at
the amusement park
walmart the nation's largest employer is
taking it a step further
requiring employees to wear masks in
high infection areas
regardless of their vaccination status
and the president
late yesterday told reporters there's
likely more
to come
in all probability by the way we had a
good day
yesterday almost a million people got
vaccinated
about half a million of those people for
the first time with a second shot
and so i'm hopeful that people are
beginning to realize how essential it is
that's what dolores armenta did she got
the shot
it was hard for me to decide as well and
ruben chavez got the shot too this week
mentally i feel like better but even the
vaccinated need to be
careful dr anthony fauci delivered more
sobering news yesterday that vaccinated
people
who do have a breakthrough infection are
clearly capable of transmitting
the infection to an uninfected person
and with the fast spreading delta
variant
the risk of getting sick is playing out
loud
i need every single force in this crowd
at this weekend's lollapalooza music
festival in chicago
masks are not mandatory but proof of
vaccinations or a negative cova test
are required i need a vaccination card
in your hands
the mayor is letting the show go on
despite warnings it could easily be a
super spreader event
for example more than a thousand covet
cases were reportedly linked to a dutch
music festival this month
about 20 thousand people attended with
protocols similar to lollapalooza
and according to the cdc about 35
thousand vaccinated people per week are
becoming infected
but that's a microscopic fraction just
two one hundredths of one percent
of the 164 million people who are fully
vaccinated
health experts maintain the best
protection against the virus
is one of the vaccines jeff okay michael
thank you very much